étranger
[Musique]
Johnny Utah's Surf Shop
ouais cool c'est Johnny Utah es-tu allé
au Johnny Utah Surf Shop il n'y a
pas de Johnny Utah Surf Shop as-tu fait
ce t-shirt non je l'avais pour mon anniversaire
c'est aujourd'hui en fait donc oh vraiment c'est  un
cadeau pas du tout petite amie ouais vraiment cool
mec joyeux anniversaire merci je
me demande ce que les gens te disent
Industries en entends-tu plus bonjour M.
faible ou bonjour M. Anderson en ce moment
bonjour M. Wick est un peu en avance M. Wick
et vous pourriez avoir bonjour M. Wick  maintenant
bonjour Michelle semaine, ce serait cool,
je veux dire, c'est vraiment amusant d'avoir ça, tu
sais, j'apprécie vraiment les gens qui
aiment les films et les personnages et
ouais, c'est amusant, y a-t-il quelqu'un dont tu
n'as pas encore pensé que tu rêverais
de combattre les
combats de films
euh Jackie Chan
[Applaudissements]
oh mon Dieu, Jackie Chan serait incroyable,
qu'en est-il de Carrie Anne Moss, je ne vais pas me
battre mais elle est incroyable mais euh je
préfère être à ses côtés que contre elle,
que penses-tu que John Week fait quand il
ne tue pas les gens, penses-tu qu'il a
des passe-temps
ouais, à l'origine, nous pensions qu'avec le
personnage, il avait restauré de vieux livres,
des livres reliés en cuir,
que pouvez-vous nous dire sur la ballerine, je veux
dire, êtes-vous dedans ouais, alors Len Wiseman
dirige la ballerine que John Wick fait
une apparition, donc j'ai pu travailler là-dessus
pendant environ une semaine, c'était amusant, donc est-ce que
ça arrive avant ou avec euh, nous
le plaçons après le chapitre trois et
avant le chapitre quatre, tout comme l'univers de John Wick
va s'étendre, nous '  Je verrai, je
ne sais pas, nous verrons ouais, ce qui se passerait
si John Wick pensait à Etan Hunt ou à
Tom Cruise qui gagnerait euh tu sais quoi,
je ne pense pas que ces personnages se
battraient, ils auraient un
whisky à la place, peut-être ouais  prenons un
whisky ou peut-être que nous nous aiderions les uns les autres,
alors la semaine de John est consacrée aux règles,
quelle serait votre règle, votre règle numéro un
euh
[Musique]
Je ne sais pas si vous établissez ces règles
et ensuite elles les enfreignent euh  euh, je ne suis pas bon
avec les règles parce que tu espères que tu
travailles avec des gens qui ont une
compréhension mutuelle où tu n'as pas besoin de
règles tu as baisé Donnie Yen pour Johnny
mc4, comment c'était face à lui parce que j'ai
entendu dire qu'il frappait très fort  avec
sa canne, il le fait ouais, il est de très haut
niveau, il est si rapide, il est si talentueux, il est
tellement expérimenté, c'est une légende
et avoir la chance d'interagir avec
lui aussi ce qui était écrit était euh la façon
dont il basait vraiment son action sur le
personnage, je le pense  Cela n'aurait pas dû être
une surprise, mais la façon dont il a travaillé
était très proche de celle de Chad et moi.
Il est si compétent qu'il prenait la
chorégraphie, il la personnalisait et
euh, très spéciale, les scènes d'action de
ce film sont vraiment folles et mais  est-ce qu'il y a
des moments où tu as peur on fait une
scène qui se déroule entre
euh trafic c'était une séquence qui a eu de
réelles conséquences donc on avait des
cascadeurs professionnels pendant qu'on se battait,
celle-là était probablement la plus dangereuse
mais tu dois avoir des journées vraiment épuisantes
ouais ouais mais c'est ce qui rend ça amusant
tu sais sans cet épuisement il
n'y a pas de plaisir parmi toutes les co-stars que tu as eu dans
ta carrière qui a été une
inspiration pour toi tu sais j'ai eu
l'opportunité de travailler avec tellement de
grands artistes je  je vais le laisser au
chapitre 4 de John Wick pour travailler avec Lawrence
Fishburne a été vraiment très spécial
dans ma vie et ma carrière et les
amoureux des animaux vous approchent-ils depuis la semaine de John
parce que vous avez tué des centaines de personnes
mais vous épargnez toujours les chiens ouais, euh
ouais  les gens viennent toujours vers moi et
parlent comme si je ne pouvais pas regarder, je
ne pouvais pas regarder et je comprends totalement
pendant que tu fais ce que tu fais
Mercy